16 avril 1970 un glissement de terrain
au plateau d'assy emporte 71 vie
il ya pratiquement plus d'espoir
le plateau d'assy en haute savoie
là-haut sont nichées des sanatoriums ce
printemps 1970 189 enfants atteints de
tuberculose et leurs accompagnateurs y
séjournent jusqu'à la catastrophe
dans la nuit du 16 avril peu après
minuit la terre glisse labousse hamas
deux bâtiments sont emportés j'ai
découvert de graves à la tête
je me suis mise à hurler au secours au
secours au secours je passe convient un
quart d'heure payantes sont dérangés
sont et falling onze jours plus tôt le 5
avril
un première événement a alerté le groupe
sur place une avalanche mineurs avaient
poussé des résidents à évacuer fait
réintégrer le
les enfants dans leur dortoir pour y
passer la nuit parce qu'ils avaient
l'habitude et que c'est là qu'ils
étaient le plus tranquille après l'avis
d'experts le directeur du centre
monsieur couvent est loin d'envisager le
danger à venir c'est ce qu'il explique
le 22 avril 1970 17 jours après
l'avalanche
onze jours après le glissement de
terrain il n'est pas jugé nécessaire
d'affoler les familles en les prévenant
qu'ils avaient eu de la terre qui était
tombé derrière une décision est prise de
rester dans les bâtiments pourtant une
accompagnatrice raconte je suis allé le
lendemain dans le dortoir des petits
garçons et j'ai vraiment constaté les
fissures dans les mieux dans le fond du
dortoir
cela vous est scandalisé qu'elles ont
l'air franchement et surtout je savais
qu'il allait remettre les enfants de
l'avis des experts après le premier
éboulement et est il fiable
fallait-il réinvestir les lieux s'il ya
un responsable a désigné qui est il pour
répondre à ces questions
des rescapés porte plainte contre x et
d'étouffer premier glissement de terrain
c'est ça bilan définitif du glissement
de terrain 71 morts dont 56 enfants
l'enquète déterminera que l'avalanche du
5 avril ne pouvait annoncer la
catastrophe ans jours plus tard du
plateau d'assy il ne reste que des
éboulis un souvenir encore prégnant
aujourd'hui sur place et une plaque à la
mémoire des disparus
[Musique]